Michelle Donovan the new education  secretary in post for about 36 hours had  to now resign she took over from Nadeem  zahari when he became Chancellor she has  now resigned so there are barely there's  basically no ministers in the education  department there's only a Lord's  Minister they've all gone and in her  resignation letter Michelle Donald says  she remains very worried about the  prospect of no ministers in the  department as we approach results day  and anxious time of course for students  she said she pleaded with the Prime  Minister yesterday I pleaded with you to  do the right thing and resign for the  sake of our country and our party both  of which are more important than any one  person she says we've put us in an  impossible situation but as someone who  values Integrity I have no choice so  she's gone and the clamor for Boris  Johnson to go is now deafening